hello everyone and welcome to game 7 of
the World Chess Championship match
between Yani publisher and the dean
liren uh I'm uh I apologize as my voice
is not working properly so I will not be
able to make a full video I've tried but
my voice completely cracks up after a
few minutes so I'm just gonna give you
the short version and only once my voice
improves I'm gonna do a very detailed
version as I usually do so basically
what happened here after E4 uh ding
played onto E6 he went for the French
defense which is a huge surprise it's
usually in this Championship being
replied with E5 to pawn to D4 we have D4
D5 Knight the D2 the tarash variation of
the French and now Pawn to C5 Knight G2
F3 we have a trade here captures
captures Knight to F6 and now e captures
on D5 a lot of horsing around here 92 to
F3 and now Bishop to A7 usually Bishop
to B4 is played here so Bishop t7 made
the nipple think a little bit uh with
Bishop to C4 and now 9 the C6 offering a
chance to mess up being spawn structure
and Yan accepts the challenge we have
captures captures and now both players
just Castle here so castles castles and
now Queen to E2 preparing Bishop to D3
so you can kick away the Knight with C4
but also attack that H7 Pawn we have
Bishop to B7 uh similar to not similarly
exactly the same as kasparov's old uh
tutor played in 1987 in a game uh
against uh Yuri grouper his name was
also Yuri but Yuri dohayan and it's
interesting because it seems like you
can contest the bishop with Bishop to A6
but this would actually be pretty bad
because after captures captures and
queen B6 the White Queen has no business
being there so not uh not a lot to enjoy
so after Bishop to B7 Bishop to D3 was
played and this is now a completely new
game
uh we have Night the story Queen to C7
and now Queen to E4 nepo just uh goes
for checkmate here we have Knight to F6
everyone expected G6 here uh but the
being plays Knight to F6 and this is
where the position really uh opened up
Queen to H4 now threatens some Bishop G5
captors and queen captures on H7
Checkmate IDs and pawn to C5 biting just
opens up his dark Square uh light Square
Bishop uh and here Bishop to F4 by
nipple Bishop to G5 although it looks
great after H6 you have to give up uh
the best for for two pawns if you wanted
to mean something and now it's basically
a draw after Rook D to f8 you're gonna
have to repeat moves with Queen G5 Queen
to H6 so not not spectacular so after
Bishop to F4 uh Queen to B6 was played
and now Knight the E5 binding you could
also try to win a pawn here with Bishop
captures on E7 uh on H7 but it's not
spectacular because uh black also messes
up your phone structure so Knights the
E5 was played and now Rook 8 to d8 we
have Rook 8 to E1 by nipple and this is
a spectacular move because uh so many
moves are possible here Bishop captures
on H7 is possible Bishop to G5 is
possible Knights the G4 is possible I'm
just going to show Knight the G4 because
it's uh I mean it's really a wonder
you're gonna have to play real
characters on G3 otherwise you're just
gonna get checkmated with check and
Checkmate so Rook captures on D3 C
counters and not Knight the D5 with a an
attack on the queen and the bishop here
and now uh if you go Bishop to G5 you
lose the game because after F6 you have
to move the bishop and now F5 comes with
an attack on the Knight end of the queen
so you're gonna have to uh play Queen
back to G3 and now you can go for
anything even H5 is enough let's say
Knight the three Ponte H4 Knight
captures and E5 attacks the black queen
and now after Bishop captures and queen
T3 you get this position Queen to B7 the
pawn is very nice here the bishop pair
is fully operational the queen there's a
battery going after the G2 Pawn uh it
would be uh it would be great for for
black so not really uh something to look
forward to this Knight to G4 move so
that's why Nepal kept the attention he
played Rook 81 now prepares um
uh prepares The Rook lift here and now
we have Ponte G6 binding finally taking
care of that uh and the situation on the
clock is over an hour for nipple in some
37 minutes for Ding and here at Bishop
to G5 we have rooked the D4 attacking
the queen here Queen to H3 and now Queen
to C7 uh this is the by by far the the
best move for Ding and it took him a bit
of a time to find it uh another moves
you could consider are Knights the D5
and uh now you go into Knight D7
attacking the queen and now you have to
play Knight to F4 you can't really allow
this checks on Knight to F4 attacks the
queen and now Bishop captures and just
the world captures on D7 Bishop to E5
puts pressure on this uh on the dark
squares but after Rook after d8 it's
perfectly fine now Bishop can come to a
fate and you defend everything
uh so here Queen to C7 binding B3
stopping in the future C4 ideas Knight
to H5 and now Pawn to F for font F4 is
very nice by nipple uh you could uh
again can consider many other moves like
Bishop to H6 you can consider Bishop
capture Sun E7 capturing here isn't
ideal because after captures and
captures in C3 there's this very nasty
Rook to H for move now the queen for me
7 guards the H4 square and now after the
queen moves you can play Knight to F4
and it just looks really really bad like
Pawn to F3 Queen is coming to G5 uh and
uh not the best so instead after Knight
H5 we have quanta F4 by nepo and now
Bishop to D6 uh we have pawned the C3
and uh in order to play uh Bishop to D6
you really have to know what to play uh
on Pawn to C3 so C3 was played and now
comes Knight captures on F4 uh Bishop
captures on F4 better for nipple would
be Rook captures and F4 but it seems uh
he missed an idea the problem is after
Bishop captures an E5 5 you can't place
the characters on D4 because then Bishop
captures an F4 comes and if Bishop
captures an F4 just Queen captures uh an
F4 so that's uh the problem black will
will be much better here and you can't
really go for The Rook be uh for the uh
Rook with the bishop because then Bishop
F6 and you can't really stop Checkmate
so the thing is here you have to find
Bishop captures on G6 that's the move
and now after each captures and G6 C
captures on D4 again uh you cannot
capture The Rook because Bishop to F6
now will be definitely Checkmate here
you're gonna have to play C characters
on D4 and now after Bishop to F6 you
will have to trade Checkmate is coming
so you have to trade count press
captures and you get this position where
uh nepo is up the exchange but the ding
has the monster bishop and the past D
Pawn so I don't know definitely uh
definitely could be crazy but instead
nipple went for Bishop capture some F4
now comes Rook captures Rook captures on
F4 and now
E5 we have rooked the H4 putting
pressure on H7 but the ding just plays
Rook to d8 he keeps the
uh the the tension the problem is if you
play Bishop captures on C3 then you just
allow Bishop captures and G6 attacking
the bishop and putting pressure on the
H7 pawn and if Bishop captures anyone
Bishop captures and H7 King G7 it looks
like you shouldn't be able to survive
this but you actually can Rook G4 came
to F6 and now Queen the E3 you can't go
for this because the bishop covers the
H4 Square so Queen to E3 King to E7 and
now let's say queen capture Sunny one
now Queen to D6 and the ding is
perfectly fine uh so while you could
play it uh maybe you allow a bit too
much King walking so Rook to d8 was
played now comes Bishop E4 offering a
trade of light Square Bishops because
let's face it now that G6 was played
dings Bishop is much scarier than nepo's
Bishop on on D3 so captures captures and
now Rook to D5 just defending that
Bishop here rooked the H4 putting
pressure on H7 and now comes Queen to D6
biting you could also consider H5 but
the thing shows that this is not a
threat if you play Queen Rook captures
on H7 Rook D1 and black wins the game
white has to resign here uh this is
hanging and also if you move the queen
The Rook here is hanging you don't have
Rook date shade so it's a pretty
terrible position for black so instead
the Queen the E3 was played by Nepal now
Ponte H5 binding making the position
even better for him now The Rook really
has only a few squares G3 now comes
Bishop to F6 attacking the rook and you
don't have Rook F4 because Bishop G5 so
Rook the C4 was played and now Pawn to H
forbiding and here you can really uh
feel how red black is putting pressure
on White's position and here uh G
captures an H4 there are moves you could
consider like Queen to F4 which are
objectively better but the thing was
very low on the clock he had five
minutes and nipple really wanted to
capitalize on that and I'm sure you know
what uh what happened there and here uh
ding went into a thing he had five
minutes on the clock and he thought for
like five minutes and he played uh Rook
to D2 and he was down to 45 seconds and
he still has eight moves to make in 45
seconds that's absolutely insane uh as
there is no increment so here Rook the
E2 was played nepo of course has to
defend against Queen captures on H2 so
he played this fairly quickly Rook D2
and now dink has to go back Rook to D5
just in order to try and hold this but
he played Rook to D3 and now feel free
to pause the video and win the game for
Nepal while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
wonderful move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Queen
captures and C5 this is what um uh this
is what nepo played and now there is
really nothing more for ding here uh
sorry about that uh here Rook the D1
check was played King to G2 and now just
Queen to D3 but there there is no
nothing here to try The Rook is hanging
not just Rook to F2 going after the
bishop King to G7 and now Rook C to F4
sorry about that uh really struggling
with my voice today I have no idea
probably my my daughter brought
something back from the kindergarten but
what are you gonna do and here uh Queen
captures on C3 was played but he was
also in this position unmoved 37 that
the dingler and resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
plus also he had three seconds on the
clock so basically what we have here uh
is a World Chess Championship Game
decided by flagging incredible as that
sounds but that's exactly what happened
here uh there's no move you can make uh
it's uh I mean even if you don't capture
on C3 there's nothing real captors and
F6 is coming and that's it but now the
game would continue obviously with Queen
captures and C3 Bishop captures and Rook
captures and F7 and uh I mean nepo has
uh his Abdi exchange his upper Pawn of
course this is completely winning for
him so a great Surprise by ding he
really had something here up until this
um
a position where even H4 was played uh
even this was uh was Final in G captures
and H4 was not optimal for nipple but he
played against ding's clock he made this
move ding had uh really really think and
with five minutes on the clock he spent
all five on Rook to D2 which is
absolutely absolutely amazing uh it's a
it's a slow position that you should
probably meet with something like King
to G7 just slow play this and then you
know improve your position little by
little uh but they couldn't he went for
checkmate nepo defended and then he
blundered the entire game with Rook to
D3 so unimaginable World Chase
championship game decided by flagging uh
I mean and nepo actually actively
flagged him that's that's the incredible
thing here so you know I I I still can't
believe that this happened but yeah yeah
nipple again takes the match it is now
four to three uh for Nepal uh we'll see
what the ding
brings a four game eight with the uh
with the white pieces uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed the story
for a bit of a shorter video on this
game but my voice can't handle a longer
one and I I really wanted to show this
game so really apologize for that um uh
once my once my voice returns I will I
will try to make a full video with all
the variations as there are so so many
great variations here so you know uh
stay tuned for that uh until then uh
hopefully my voice improves for game
eight uh so yeah all right that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it very
nicely done by Nepal I would like to
thank Goodman Mana Barry mcmurdock
mcwell Shirley uh yonding Gutierrez and
Paul says for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the World
Chess Championship uh see you soon